hey
i'm standing outside the matson physics
building and like everywhere else in the
country it's absolutely blanketed with
snow snow snow everywhere i love snow i
was spent yesterday building snowmen and
watching as snowflakes fell from the sky
collecting them on my hands and gloves
and showing my kids who got very very
bored very quickly at just how excited
daddy could get about snow but what
we're going to try and do is look at
snow in a little bit more detail i'm
going to collect up a cup full of it
bring it in to our resident electron
microscopist who's going to use an
electron rather than an optical an
electron microscope to look at the fine
detail the structure of the of the snow
it's a real shame that it's not snowing
at the moment because that's by far the
best because when the impact on the
ground you generally lose the crystal
structure much of the crystal structure
of the snowflake but let's let's see
what we can do with this let's see if we
can see anything interesting at all so
what chris is doing at the moment is
he's putting liquid nitrogen in so we
can actually keep the sample nice and
cool so the ice doesn't melt while he's
while he's imaging it
so where comes in it's loading onto the
the sample stage
so as he's loading it in
what we have up here this is the column
down which the electrons come the
electrons that we use for emitting but
what we're going to do is we're going to
have a sample down here
with those electrons that strike the
sample here and then we get electrons
which are back scattered off and we're
measuring those electrons with the
detector here and it's with this that we
actually build up the image
so what chris is doing here is now
progressively zooming in to look at the
structure of this snow sample that he's
put in here this this bar here
this particular bar
is is at at the moment you can see it
keeps changing it's a millimeter across
so that gives you an idea of the scale
that we've got here chris is going to
keep moving in zooming in zooming in
looking for interesting regions
this looks weird
yes there we go okay
the problem is of course getting it into
the microscope but first of all it's
fallen on the ground so we're not
looking at pristine snow crystals here
yeah
can you zoom in here that's that's a
really nice or you can see a facet so
yeah so you can really see the
crystalline structure really really
quite neatly here
and this is
50 microns across you know but they are
that's about 50 microns so again
about the width of a human hair
not down here
yeah so there we go so now we're
starting to see that the the hexagonal
structure that we'd expect for ice
crystals
but you can certainly see the facets you
can see the angles okay so over here
what we're actually looking at are the
crystal faces of of snow of snowflakes
it's it's really remarkable the amount
of detail we've got you can see the
facets it's incredibly smooth and what
chris is going to do is going to write
this wonderful christmas greeting on the
end of one of these facets he's going to
use
a focused ion beam to do that so this is
about the the the facet here is about 50
microns across that's roughly very
roughly the width of a of a hair and
he's going to to write that directly on
the end of this snowflake basically it's
basically being written by pummeling
ions charged particles in a beam into
the into the ice just basically driving
them in and ablating off of material
scattering off the of the ice
hey
all right bloody tastic
right improve the
contrast you measure chris actually can
you can you measure
excellent okay so merry christmas is 100
microns across so that's about the width
of human hair